- I want to talk
This thing is crazy cool.
Twig furniture.
A lot of people call this
Adirondack furniture, you know?
MATT: Yep.
MIKE WOLFE: Would have been
up in like, resort areas.
That could be
over 100 years old.
It's got a great look.
I see it's got a
major repair here.
What are you thinking?
$8,000.
[laughter]
I mean, I've been around
this stuff quite a bit.
I mean, this one is a
little bit different.
But they're all different,
to be honest with you,
because they're handmade.
Rosie's in my ear.
She's saying $500.
$450, work with
me a little bit.
All right, I'll do $450.
OK, very cool.
MIKE WOLFE (VOICEOVER): We
love picking the East Coast,
because there's so
much opportunity
to find Americana at its best.
That's the kind of
stuff we're looking for.
Yeah, I know where this goes.
Yeah, that's been in
this store my whole life.
I know that had to come out
of one of Rosie's classrooms.
She was a school
teacher for 44 years.
MIKE WOLFE: No kidding!
MATT: Yeah, she taught
the world to read.
And if you look at the
countries on there,
they're so old that that's got
to be from the '40s or '50s,
you know?
You look at Europe,
and it's all different.
The only thing is--
I mean, there's a lot of loss
of just little pieces of paper
all over the place
on it, where it's
starting-- but other than
that, I mean, it's really cool.
MATT: Cool enough
for you to buy it?
I'm in a selling mood, fella.
75 bucks.
Tell you what, make it $100.
It's vintage.
I'm doing it.
All right, awesome.
Thank you.
I'll do it, I'll do it.
See, and you can adjust it, so--
I never even knew
that it adjusted.
MIKE WOLFE: --so
Frank can see it.
[laughter]
You know it.
Hey, Frank, look at this
fine vintage Monticello
Distributing Company.
Ooh, I like it.
FRANK FRITZ (VOICEOVER):
The Monticello Distillery
was known for its rye whiskey.
The company was named
after Thomas Jefferson's
house, which was in Virginia.
But the distillery was
actually in Maryland.
Special reserve,
it's all whiskey.
You know what I like about this?
I mean, it's got some
nice color on it.
There is a lot going on here.
It's got horses.
It's got the hounds.
It's a metal sign.
I've seen these sell
for like around $400.
So I'm thinking like, $250?
How about $300?
How about split
it with me, $275?
- I think we can do that.
- Do that?
All right!
- $275, it's all yours.
I'm getting into the liquor
situation here, I love it.
What are you looking
at over here, Frankie?
I'm thinking this must
have been your grandfather's?
MATT: Well, both my grandfather
and my great Uncle Joe
were both dentists.
I would probably say
this was Joseph's,
just because it's here.
They actually used
this as a means
to hide the truck
from the street.
This was part
of the camouflage?
Yeah.
This would have had
milk glass shelves that
would have been inside of here.
MATT: Yeah.
FRANK FRITZ (VOICEOVER):
This is a nice item.
It has etched
glass on the front.
It has a marble top.
This is a great piece.
Well, can I make
you an offer on it?
Sure.
How about $800?
How about $850?
Leaves a little on the
bone for you, right?
Let's do it.
Yeah, you bet, let's do it.
FRANK FRITZ (VOICEOVER):
Now that Matt's
responsible for
cleaning up this place,
he's ready to get
rid of some things
that he's not
emotionally attached to.
I got that radiator
from the '31 Chevy,
Mike, I know you like that.
MIKE WOLFE: Ooh, this is cool.
I found this scale.
How about 35 bucks?
$40 and it's yours.
What do you want for
the Chevrolet grille?
'31 Chevy.
Yep.
Got the badge.
Car or truck.
The radiator's in it.
MIKE WOLFE (VOICEOVER):
I love car grills.
Because I think a lot of
the guys that designed
the cars designed them
from the grill back.
What do you think, 100 bucks?
So, $100--
$140.
[laughter]
All right, $140.
All right, this is the
second thing that's
been sold out of this truck.
- There you go.
MIKE WOLFE (VOICEOVER):
Somebody out
there is looking for this grill
to finish their restoration.
All right, Frankie.
MIKE WOLFE (VOICEOVER):
Their story
is the great American story,
to come here with nothing
and to make something that
supported so many people,
and that was such an intricate
part of their community--
that's the American dream.
Thanks for sharing your
family's history with us.
MATT: I learned a bunch
of things from them today.
So some of this stuff
is going to move,
and other people are
going to get to enjoy it.
See you guys.
FRANK FRITZ: Later, Matt.
Bye, Matt, god bless!